where's Fritzi I don't know are you
depressed no don't say it don't say it
seems like a soup are you basketball
player with your has got the same I mean
I can junker home I guess yeah I don't
play that's it you don't know hmm
here we go but I can try I try
everything
it's what's what's going on hey what are
you doing what were you doing back I was
talking some of the guys in the pod Todd
oh man that's not on here yet
where's well we are couldn't find fritzy
it was actually a good thing for our
guests
Samantha hoops hi Samantha comes in no
hug no hug never same you try to behave
you guys got me no I said you can give
her a three-second hug with than [ __ ] I
know but it's the first time we met so I
feel like you know that maybe I will all
that don't you do you want to give her a
hug I'm a hugger
oh yeah that's a whole other story yeah
all right go so here we go
this is what he lives for right here one
two three that's it so um let me give
the full introduction here to samantha
oops the Sports Illustrated swimsuit
model three times Sports Illustrated
swimsuit edition model but were you the
Rookie of the Year I was not the Rookie
of the Year but not yeah now it says you
became the face for guess and Rookie of
the Year Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
Edition well that part's a lie cuz I
wasn't but I'll take it
is there a Rookie of the Year for this
nation yeah every every year every
rookie gets a rookie of the year well
what do you like you get something um
yeah you actually did last year I think
she got like a little trophy she did and
it said like Rookie of the Year on it
it's like a big thing you have to get it
cuz then you get into the next edition
if you get Rookie of the Year like
you're guaranteed a spot you know how do
you get into the business of being a
swimsuit model for me I literally
applied online so I just like sending a
couple pictures my dad took like some
Polaroids I know that sounds super
creepy
that's I'm super greedy but wait wait so
your dad
yeah my dad he's a good photographer I
guess cuz I got a contract out of it but
how's the conversation come up where you
go dad I want to do this or does your
dad say you should do this no it was
actually my mom who was gonna find a job
for me after college she was like you
know you're not doing anything with your
life you need a job and I was like well
I'll just be a model so I applied online
and then all of a sudden I'm like a
model it's crazy but you have this
background though you go to Penn State
yeah what were you in kinesiology yes I
was okay so that's not like the normal
track for being a model no not at all I
think just afterwards I was like hanging
out and I'm doing really much of
anything and my mom was like you cannot
do this anymore you know I have four
sisters they all are like successful so
I just applied online yeah but did you
want to be a trainer I didn't I wanted
to be a gym teacher
a gym teacher yeah Fritzie stop what
right now I can see if they're thought
bubbles above your head right now you
would I would be kicked out of the
school
if I would have said substitute teacher
uh-huh you would have gone crazy here so
up for teacher thing I know you don't
know much about you know this group over
here but you know I'm trying to limit
his exposure we're trying to mature here
is what we're trying to do we've had
swimsuit models here before and it
hasn't gone well so we're actually
trying to take a new tact I just want to
let you know got it yeah I think you're
doing a great job
yeah sometime trying to control myself
and babe yes yes Paulie fritzy should be
careful because Samantha's boyfriend
looks like the really good-looking
Hemsworth brother that's right yeah six
nine Emsworth is a good luck the rest
one is Chris Hemsworth Liam's a jealous
of them yeah I like did you have did you
have to bring your boyfriend in did you
bring him in for a reason yeah I
followed him here he's really good at
directions so I just followed him you
you couldn't have found your way here
without your voice I could I was doing
six seven who walked in here he's my
bodyguard yeah yeah buzzkill what Paulie
this shirt has ABS on
is it is there rivalry
again with with other models um and
don't say everybody gets along you know
I'm not gonna say that there's rivalry
by any means everyone obviously wants
the cover of Sports Illustrated
especially Sports Illustrated because
it's such an iconic magazine um but I
think everyone in the end is actually
happy for everyone at least I am I can
only speak for myself
can you angle to get on the cover I wish
I would have done it by now if I could
do it but how would you go about you
know hey I really love to be on the
cover
yeah that's what I would say I'd be like
hey how are my pictures you know can I
get on that cover but it would never
work but but it's it's one thing to be a
model we've seen models who then turn it
into a career Brooklyn Decker became
more Chrissy Teigen Heidi Klum so how do
you go from somebody who is known for a
still photo to then becoming a
personality that's a really good
question I think you need the right
people behind you and I think you need
to want it and I think you need to just
go after and get it yeah but Chrissy
uses social media yeah but that's how
everyone uses social media now I need to
get on that train because I've been kind
of like boycotting in a little bit but I
really need to start using it to my
advantage because that's you guys share
everything though yeah I know I need to
be more transparent for sure but it's
how you do it I think do you want to act
no well you don't well that's refreshing
yeah
yeah I mean I definitely want to let
people know like what I like to do and
that kind of stuff but then again it's
like another full-time job you know
Sports Illustrated is a full-time job
now with all the um web stuff that they
do and you know appearances that you go
to an events and everything which is
awesome are you sports fan I am a sports
man I like hockey and basketball the
most though because I understand I grew
up playing field hockey so I like hockey
when the issues come Sports Illustrated
issue comes out how does it work with
your dad like does he like his friends
um his friends are a different story but
my dad's good his friends get like I'm
not gonna say creepy but you know
they're like can you sign this for me
and then
feel a little weird cuz it's my dad's
friend but but these are people that you
grew up around right yeah like neighbors
and they'll go for you but I guess like
they don't really look at it like me in
a bikini and they just like see me I
think does that make sense yes whoo well
it's good that she's got some experience
with creepy old guys yes ya hear that
Ben well here yeah yeah pretty much
prepares you for this right here I kind
of like creepy old guys you do yeah well
that's very say hello to my little
friend over here this is like the best
day ever
he he tried to be a photographer one
time how does that go just with language
oh yeah it didn't go well recreate that
because he'd known that wore me out and
she deserves better
yeah I would but he thought that you
you're like the photographer is very
suggestive instead of just sort of
saying nice things about what you're
doing he thought it was more of creepy
cuz in those late nights cinematic
movies that's they portray that's like
it you know you're dirt give me that
look you're dirty yet you know what this
is what they do so I thought that's what
they do in real life that doesn't work
that that's not how it works I mean it
can work if it's done properly but it's
not like creepy what you want to shoot
so it's like you expect the photographer
to be like oh yeah that's hot do that
again
you know that kinda stuff that's got to
be the greatest job ever seriously is
there a better job I don't know idea
okay give me the dialogue if I'm a male
model okay and you're the photographer
it's the same for both I think it goes
both ways okay so how would it sound
like oh yeah that's super yeah give me
those eyes again that's hot super hot
can I beat ya gonna turn turn your head
a little bit yeah Anglet yeah perfect
super sexy again yeah yeah perfect what
if I don't look good they would tell you
they would yeah they would tell you
either like really nice or very blunt
like that is not what you should be
doing have you ever you want for this is
where you follow up with the pepperoni
questions and stuff I'm just trying to
help you out a little bit what's that
mister reconfirm what we've heard from
other sports
tsumo do you want tell her there was a
Chrissy Teigan it was it was a Brooklyn
Decker who initially told me about it
right that the that the person taking
the pictures or someone on the set if
they say pepperoni that means that
there's something like your pepperoni
right there's something showing there
that they need to do something you have
a code word
um that's do I have a code word for like
a pepperoni if the top goes down is what
the reason why they said pepperoni and I
just like a look at their face they're
always just like and I'm like okay then
you know you have to cover it yeah
exactly yeah do you ever have you ever
gone out late the night before shoot you
know I have and it was one time in
particular I can think of when I was in
Miami of course um I did go out and I
don't know how I lived through the shoot
but I totally killed it you did I killed
it yeah I think I actually like did
better because I had to be more mentally
prepared you know I was like oh my god
I'm still hungover the best place you've
ever been to shoot st. Lucia yeah it's
pretty
yeah they don't do anything like hoboken
or something there's no like good good I
mean I you know I went to Oregon oh yeah
and it was like why would they cold
what are you doing in Oregon shooting
record this decision oh you were I
thought you go to all these glamorous
spots well last year we did the 50
states so it's kinda cool because I've
never been to Oregon and I was like on
the Goonies Beach and it was really cool
I never got Forgan what else did you get
we're gonna Napa and I actually like Oh
drove up yeah like a road trip so let's
see you get to represent Sports
Illustrated at the Super Bowl the Indy
500 right yep coming up oh you're going
to the Indy 500 coming up nice yeah are
you riding in a car I don't believe so
but that would be really exciting if I
could yeah oh yeah I think you should
while you're there I mean I totally
would just so you know fritzy she moved
down to LA she lived on an air mattress
and she had no car and look how far
she's got yes that's one of the all your
kiddies out there is like when things
like look like it things are roughing
why they get help if you look like that
damn and you come out here
she had the courage to go out and chase
your dreams and go out to LA and you
know you didn't have the this will never
happen forget it I'll just stay put why
I am no that's the sum to be said for
them and you meet like the the other
Hemsworth brother the night look like
Thor Thor Hemsworth right out of a
poster I know and believe me when he
walked in yeah you surveyed the whole
room here and the handshake was a little
more firm than I thought like okay dude
we get it all right tough guy you know
his eyes are tan his eyeballs are white
you get your eyes Tim his eyelids are
tan
yeah but the optometrist must frown upon
this guy begins I think I got he's gonna
you got a spray tan by the way I got
dude came in with a spray tan he's you
know I know it's not a spray it's not
it's real he's made up as you are
who's got more makeup on your boyfriend
are you I do you do but it's close you
got Thor over there I think he's sort of
laughing over there right jobs I want
yeah I want yeah look ahead laugh yeah
yeah look who's laughing now
right I'm stuck with you guys he leaves
with the girl indeed Samantha thank you
for coming in be a great sport we
appreciate it
Samantha hoops the Sports Illustrated
swimsuit model and on social media
wait is there a plug for social media I
think it's just Samantha hoops
let's underscore that's yeah yeah that's
on Instagram
okay so Samantha hoops the three-time
Sports Illustrated swimsuit edition
model and she was not she was not Rookie
of the Year I was not you were not oh
thank you for joining us I will come
back this is the Dan Patrick show
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience